es la primera vez que francia decide
publicar imágenes de este tipo con
drones esto mientras parís da por
terminada su operación militar de casi
una década en mali las fuerzas francesas
abandonaron la base militar de goz y el
martes un día después vehículos de
fabricación china supuestamente
utilizados por el ejército maliense
llegaron a la base abandonada las
imágenes afirman que los soldados
malienses pasaron la noche en el
exterior y según el ejército francés los
mercenarios del grupo ruso agner
durmieron en una tienda de campaña más
tarde el miércoles un tweet enviado
desde una cuenta falsa hablaba de los
crímenes cometidos en la base por las
fuerzas francesas ya retiradas las
imágenes de vigilancia filmadas el
jueves parecen mostrar a los soldados
cubriendo los cadáveres con arena luego
otro tweet enviado desde la misma cuenta
falsa muestra un vídeo de la escena que
acababa de ser montada las imágenes
publicadas por francia muestran a los
soldados filmando los cuerpos que habían
cubierto con arena esta es la base
militar de ghosts y evacuada por las
tropas francesas a principios de esta
semana y a unos tres kilómetros de
distancia se encuentra el escenario
montado
se trata de una maniobra de
desinformación que se estaba gestando y
los militares franceses decidieron por
primera vez hacerla pública a un público
net francia y eeuu han acusado a los
mercenarios de wagner de desplegarse en
mali sin embargo las autoridades locales
dicen que están en el país como
instructores militares la última
revelación del ejército francés llega
cuando las relaciones entre francia y
malí se hunden aún más